Who could have imagined that a man who
spent his days feeding pigeons in a park
near the New York Public Library was one
of the most brilliant minds in the world.
Nikola Tesla was so smart that he
could picture all his ideas and
the designs for them in his head.
He didn’t need models or drawings.
But although the Serbian-American was a
famous inventor, he died penniless after
his most ambitious project came crashing down.
How dramatic a turn his life took.
At one point, he could have easily
been the richest person on the planet.
Royalty payments on his alternating current
power system were worth an absolute fortune,
hundreds of millions of
dollars adjusted for inflation.
Today, our world is still
predominantly powered by AC in
which the flow of electricity changes
direction periodically. As a result,
it suffers less energy loss when
transmitted over long distances.
On the other hand, Thomas Edison’s
direct current - DC - travels in
only one direction and is tough
to transmit over long distances.
AC is the type of electric current
generated by most power plants,
including Tesla’s plant at Niagara Falls.
Niagara Falls started the
electrification of the world.
Tesla and American industrialist George
Westinghouse built the world’s first
hydroelectric power plant here in 1895,
using AC to harness the power of the falls.
After such a great success, Tesla
could have retired very comfortably,
but instead, he was determined to outdo himself
by achieving a new form…of global communication.
Trouble is…he had no money to turn
his latest dream into reality.
How can that be? Considering his
AC system made him very wealthy.
Westinghouse purchased Tesla’s AC
patents for $60,000 in the form of
$5,000 cash and 150 shares in Westinghouse
Electric and Manufacturing Company.
Westinghouse also agreed to pay Tesla royalties
based on how much electricity he could sell,
amounting to $2.50 per horsepower
of electrical capacity sold.
Tesla should have been rich. But he
wasn’t. Because…of his kind heart.
But Westinghouse's company suffered
greatly as it battled Edison’s company,
in which Edison tried to show
how dangerous Tesla’s AC was.
Westinghouse was nearly bankrupt
and industrialist J.P. Morgan intended to
starve out Westinghouse’s company and buy
up Tesla’s patents in an effort
to dominate the energy market.
Westinghouse begged Tesla for
relief from having to pay the
promised royalties to try to save his company.
In response, in what can only be described
as a gesture of pure selflessness,
Tesla tore up his contract…he was
so moved by his friend’s pleas.
Nikola Tesla single-handedly
saved the Westinghouse company.
He was grateful to George Westinghouse, his friend
who believed in him, who never swindled him.
And besides, Tesla had even
bigger ideas to pursue.
Yet walking away from the royalties
would come back to haunt him.
Because it left him struggling financially…to
the point where it dashed his ultimate dream.
After the success of Niagara Falls,
Tesla returned to his lab. There was
nothing he loved more than experimenting.
Even the fire that gutted his
New York laboratory couldn’t
stop him. We don’t know why it caught fire.
In 1891, he had invented the remarkable
Tesla coil, which produced high-voltage,
high-frequency alternating current electricity.
With high frequencies, he pioneered the use of
x-rays for medical purposes. This is
an x-ray Tesla took of his own hand.
But that paled in comparison to the time
he waved vacuum tubes around like a Jedi,
illuminating them wirelessly after having
transmitted energy through the air!
The wireless transmission of energy
became his lifelong obsession.
He imagined a wireless globe - transmitting
free electricity across the Atlantic with
no wires…and took his idea to the
wealthy American banker J.P. Morgan.
Morgan put up $150,000 to
build a giant transmission
tower at Wardenclyffe on Long Island, New York.
Tesla imagined that it would
be the first of a network of
towers worldwide. He believed that these
towers would allow him to send electricity
through the atmosphere which anyone with
the correct equipment could then tap into.
This image is an artistic impression
kindly supplied to me by Alan Bellows
of Damn Interesting; the real tower
never crackled with electricity.
Tesla explained at the time: “…it will be
possible for a businessman in New York to dictate
instructions, and have them instantly appear
in type at his office in London or elsewhere”.
He was well ahead of his time. It
was incredibly prescient of him to
imagine a global wireless communication system
similar to what the internet offers us today.
But not long after construction began in
1901, Tesla started to run out of money.
He appealed to J.P. Morgan for
more financing without any luck.
Investors were instead throwing their
support behind a young Italian inventor.
In 1901, Guglielmo Marconi successfully sent a
radio signal from England to Newfoundland, Canada.
He used Tesla’s radio patents to do it.
Tesla realized his coils could transmit
and receive powerful radio signals and he
applied for radio patents which the
U.S. Patent Office granted in 1900.
So Marconi’s feat didn’t bother Tesla,
who remarked to one of his engineers:
"Marconi is a good fellow. Let him continue.
He is using seventeen of my patents."
Marconi tried to file radio patents
himself in the U.S., but the Patent
Office turned down repeated applications as
it argued they were too similar to Tesla’s.
However, as Tesla found out the
hard way, things can change.
In 1904, the Patent Office reversed
its earlier decisions and awarded
Marconi a patent for the invention of the radio.
The reason behind the reversal
has never been explained.
Some suspect the powerful backing
Marconi received in the United States,
including that by Edison, played a role.
Marconi was credited as the inventor
of the radio…and became rich.
He even won the Nobel Prize
in Physics as a result!
Tesla was furious and sued the Marconi Company for
patent infringement yet couldn’t afford to
litigate a case against a big corporation.
He also couldn’t find anyone interested in
investing more money in his tower of dreams.
In 1917, Tesla’s tower was
dismantled to pay off his creditors.
Tesla was in debt to the heirs of the Waldorf
Astoria Hotel where he had been staying.
When his friend and wealthy investor
John Jacob Astor died on the Titanic,
Astor’s heirs demanded that Tesla pay his debt.
He did so by demolishing his tower
and selling the scrap metal.
When his greatest dream was
out of reach, Tesla lamented:
”It is not a dream. It is a simple feat
of scientific electrical engineering,
only expensive—blind,
faint-hearted, doubting world!”
Tesla began to withdraw from that world.
He showed signs of obsessive-compulsive disorder.
He was obsessed with the number 3 and would walk
around a block three times
before entering a building.
He’d count his steps wherever he walked.
He compulsively counted the cubic content
of bowls of soup or cups of coffee,
otherwise, his meals were not enjoyable.
Near the end of his life, he
became obsessed with pigeons.
Especially a white female pigeon.
He is believed to have said:
“…I loved that pigeon, I loved
her as a man loves a woman,
and she loved me...As long as I had
her, there was a purpose in my life.”
Tesla never married.
The pigeon apparently died in his arms, and, at
that point, he knew his life’s work was finished.
Nikola Tesla would live out the last ten
years of his life at the New Yorker Hotel,
paid for by the Westinghouse Corporation
which also gave him a “consulting fee” of
$125 a month. This is the company that
was in debt to him for having given
up royalties worth millions of dollars for
the sake of his friend George Westinghouse.
He began to fade away into history, one of the few
exceptions being the time he turned 75
and made the cover of Time Magazine.
Tesla died in his hotel room alone on
January 7, 1943…without a penny to his name.
He was 86 years old.
A few months after his death, the U.S.
Supreme Court overturned Marconi’s
radio patent in favor of Tesla’s.
But the Court had a selfish reason
for doing so; the Marconi Company
was suing the U.S. government for
use of its patents in World War I.
So, the Court avoided the lawsuit
by simply restoring Tesla’s patent.
When I worked on an earlier video
about Nikola Tesla some pointed
out that The Forgotten Genius
was not an apt thumbnail title.
Personally, I grew up in Canada learning
much more about Thomas Edison, an American,
than Nikola Tesla, an immigrant who
was born in present-day Croatia.
But perhaps viewers have a point,
and he really isn’t forgotten.
Today, Tesla is once again capturing the public’s
imagination. Because an electric
car company bears his name.
Elon Musk’s company paid homage
to Nikola Tesla with a dazzling
display of drones earlier this year that
formed a visage of the brilliant engineer.
Tesla is undoubtedly one of the
most famous figures in STEM,
and if you’ve been inspired by his brilliance
and wish to brush up on your math, science,
and computer science skill, Brilliant
is a great way to learn interactively.
And it’s FREE for you to
try out with my custom link.
I personally use Brilliant to go through their
Logic puzzles which I find have
strengthened my reasoning skills.
I know my viewers especially love
their computer science fundamentals
course where you can program
drones in an Amazon warehouse.
Their Scientific Thinking course is full of
interactive exercises that will give you a
solid handle on the principles of engineering
and the laws of physics. In this exercise,
you have to make the bridge as rigid as
possible with as few beams as possible.
And if you’d like to improve your math
skills, I’d highly recommend the Every
Math course where you can see numbers
in a new light, in everyday contexts.
There’s something for everyone - whether
you’re a student or already working.
Brilliant is free for you to try out if you
head to the custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who
sign up with my custom link will get 20% off
Brilliant’s annual Premium membership which
gives you unlimited access to all the course
offerings including the most advanced courses.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.